hast du eigentlich schon mal daran
gedacht ein kochbuch zu schreiben
in der tat weil mir fällt immer super
sache nein ich mische rote beete saft
mit cola schmeckt super ihr müsst das
mal probieren es ja auch cola mit
rotwein ist also eigentlich philipp des
quali pc für diesen clip wir reden heute
übers kochen ich habe mir ja die
elisabeth bronfen auch zugelegt weil ich
fan bin von ihr weil sie eine
literaturwissenschaftlerin ist die ich
mit großem interesse verfolge und wissen
wollte was sie zum thema kochen zu sagen
hat und natürlich gefallen mit dieser
ausflüge zu shakespeare zu goethe zur
hitchcock und so weiter ich finde dass
dieses buch sehr schön zeigt wie man
kulturelles verbinden kann mit der
kultur des kochens was gefällt mir sehr
gut es hat so etwas sinnliches etwas
leidenschaftliches was lustvoller sie
hat es auch sehr gut gefallen ich finde
nur bei diesen ganzen sachen so kochen
als lebenskunst und entspannung fehlt
mir immer so ein bisschen diese andere
seite nämlich wenn ich zum beispiel
meine bessere hälfte beim kochen erlebe
dann kommt irgendwann der moment einfach
nur noch geflucht würde dieses narrativ
möchte ich mal sagen von kochen als oase
der ruhe und meditation ist glaube ich
nicht unbedingt immer in der
lebenspraxis und was sie eben auch macht
und das gefällt mir so gut sind nimmt
ganz ganz wertvolle zutaten zum teil und
dann beschäftigt sie sich aber auch ganz
stark damit also mit dieser cucina
povera also resteessen diese reste essen
hat mich offen gestehen ein bisschen an
nigel lawson ist eine englische
fernsehköchen die ich auch sehr liebe
die aber auch um mich dann immer wieder
frappiert wenn sie so sachen macht wie
ok heute mache ich rest also ich guck
mal schnell hier in meiner kammer ups
ich hab hier noch mal einen halben roma
wenn man wie in einer losen oder
elisabeth bronze neben anfang davon kann
man natürlich auch mit diesem halben
hummer sehr schnell ein zauberhaftes
resteessen machen ich finde dieses buch
sehr attraktiv ich will nur darauf
hinweisen dass es auch manchmal schön
ist wenn man zum beispiel ein großes
weiches stück toast nimmt was man nicht
kostet dann schmiert man dick butter
drauf gegangen und man eine tüte
kartoffelchips und ich liebe die chips
klein hacken chips auf dieses butter
toast und tut oben noch eine scheibe
weiches tuch
und ist nein das entschuldigt bitte das
geht gar nicht kannst du dich erinnern
an andreas beck wird es die gesellschaft
des singularitäten der sagt jedes
individuum heutzutage muss sich seine
eigene lebenswelt so bauen dass es ein
seine identität besonders stark
hervorhebt und ich denke das kochen
vielleicht ein teil davon ist er sagt ja
auch dass wir in einer gesellschaft
leben wo selbst banalste produkte zum
beispiel himbeeren mit geschichten
versehen werden müssen
also das sind dann nachhaltige
lokalgeschichte himbeeren genau und in
dem moment dann auch denjenigen die
dieses produkt konsumiert also himbeere
auszeichnen irgendwie distinguiert genau
in aber das ist ja eigentlich auch das
worüber wir gerade gesprochen haben ja
genauso immer wieder versucht möglichst
kompliziert dass du gerade gesprochen
haben meine damen und herren ich mache
ich hatte ungefähr zehn jahren kein
super du ja da sind ein traumduo jetzt
hören wir mit diesem spot auf